What's up, all you spiritual vagabonds,
all you conscious roamers,
you beautiful shape-shifters and seekers?
My name is Rich Roll.
I am keeper of the sacred podcast flame here with good news,
because after quite the extended respite,
today we return to swim in waters metaphysical
because master of the Kundalini arts
Guru Singh is in the house,
and "Guru Multiverse" is back.
In addition to being a good friend,
Guru Singh is a celebrated master spiritual teacher.
He's a third generation Sikh Yogi.
He's an author, an accomplished musician,
a father, a grandfather.
Basically, this is a guy who is a gift to humanity,
a man who has been teaching and studying Kundalini yoga
for the past 40 years,
all of which you can learn more about
at kundaliniuniversity.com.
Today, we process this most unusual year
with strategies to emerge healthy and whole.
We also discuss our addiction to this idea of normalcy.
We identify the growth opportunities
in the wake of what we have collectively weathered.
We also weigh the pros and cons
of incremental versus revolutionary change
and explore many other topics.
Make sure to stick around to the end.
Guru Singh takes us out with a beautiful song.
It's great to be back,
so please hit that subscribe button and let's do the thing.
This is me and Guru Singh.
So good to see you.
It's just really special.
We were chatting earlier today
and I was trying to remember the last time that I saw you.
I mean, the last time that a "Guru Corner" episode went up
was probably a year and a half ago,
but that came out quite a bit of time
after we actually recorded it.
So, I'm not sure we've seen each other in-
Two years?
Almost two years.
As I recall, it was July of 2019.
July or August.
Too long.
Yeah, way too long.
But you've been up in Seattle,
recently back to Los Angeles.
Yeah, we are now truly bilocated, and we're-
So cosmopolitan of you.
We look at our lives as being
a very large house with a highway for a hallway
between the two extensions of the house.
And that is the Interstate 5
between Seattle and Los Angeles.
Do you make the drive or do you fly?
We drive.
So, all your kids and your grandkids are up in Seattle.
That's right.
And you know, being able to,
which was not something we were able to do before
because we were tied to bricks and mortar, right?
We were tied to yoga centers and retreat centers.
And so, we operated out of Los Angeles,
and now we operate out of wherever
there's a high-speed internet connection.
Sure.
So, is Yoga West reopening,
or are you going all digital
with everything that you're doing?
I'm all digital.
Wow, from here on out?
From here on forward.
People say, "When are you gonna do gatherings?"
And I'm thinking to myself, why?
You know, I love the gathering,
but at a gathering you can do at most a few hundred.
But we're on the road to doing thousands of students.
And my task in life, like your task in life,
is to reach as many as possible to uplift them.
Sure.
But in your classes,
you would also livestream them
on Facebook or Instagram, et cetera.
So, you were serving that dual function
of having that in-person connection.
I mean, there is something about the energy
of being physically present with the teaching
and the ripple effect that comes with that.
I can't imagine you're not going to have
some form of gatherings in the not-too-distant future.
Well, yeah.
There will have to be,
because you know as well as I do
that I came from the stage anyway,
as a musician on stage.
That is a very important part.
But the beauty and joy of family
and the beauty and joy of navigating the ups and downs
of what we're going through right now as a world.
Well, the last time that we spoke,
we spent most of that conversation exploring grief
and the pain,
navigating the pain of loss in the wake of your grandchild
passing away as an infant.
And I thought it would be interesting
to catch up on that story,
'cause there have been some developments.
Yeah, there have been.
So, to put the end of the story first
so that it doesn't have to be tension-filled.
Within months after the passing just after birth,
36 hours after birth of our grandson Tiaga,
our daughter and son-in-law got pregnant again on purpose,
and for the other two children and for the whole family.
And we now have a nine-and-a-half-month-old granddaughter.
This is not always possible for people,
so I don't wanna try to present this as a prescription.
But as a family, we navigated the grief really, really well.
I remember our grandson, who at the time was three,
and every once in a while he would just shout out,
"I don't want my brother to die."
And this was months after it had happened.
And we would sit together
and sit inside of that emotion.
And then after a while, he would draw,
at three years old,
he would draw his own conclusions
with some guidance and some conversation.
And he would come to a place where he would say,
"But you know, he's still here.
"I still feel him, and that's okay for now."
And this is coming out of the mouth of a three-year-old
and his sister, a five-year-old at that time.
So, the last two years have been a journey
through death and birth and grief and joy.
And it reminds me of that
Isaac Newton's third law of motion,
that for every action or activity,
there's an equal and opposite,
which is kind of a law of the physical universe.
And so, this has been a really big lesson,
because even in the death of my parents
and my wife's parents,
two of which have happened over,
her parents have happened over the last two years
since I saw you last.
It was a,
it was a, okay,
we're gonna grieve in a very healthy way,
meaning we're gonna fully grieve.
But we're also going to look for the equal and opposite.
Yeah, I feel like an event of such tragic proportions
holds a lot of potential energy.
In most cases, you see that ultimately splintering
the marriage or the family unit
because the grief is too much to bear,
or the people who are reveling in that grief
are ill-equipped with healthy tools to navigate it.
And it makes those bonds and those relationships fracture.
So, to be able to weather it as a collective,
for you to be in Seattle and have that experience together
and just see the family emerge from that
more whole in some way is inspiring and instructive.
But as somebody who's,
you've been around a couple of decades at this point.
You've experienced loss and grief and death
and every permutation in between.
Was there something different about this experience
that you learned from
that finds its way into how you teach
and instruct your students?
Yes.
The avenue at the juncture of death
that expands the tragedy
beyond just the normal grieving
is the avenue of guilt and blame.
Oftentimes, for example,
our grandson Tiaga passed away 36 hours after birth
and he had never really, really got a hold of his breath.
He really, there was intubation
and there was mechanized breathing.
And that was sustaining him, and they thought,
okay, let's see if that can hold him
while other things are correcting.
But the other things didn't correct.
Ultimately, after about 30 hours,
our daughter, as I told you before, said,
"I just wanna hold my baby."
Because you couldn't hold the baby.
The baby was in a refrigeration kind of mattress
and had a lot of tubes and everything.
And there was really no path forward
through the medical profession.
And so they said, "Okay, let's just take everything out.
"Let me hold the child until he passes."
That time was so precious for both our daughter, my wife.
I hadn't yet arrived in Seattle,
but my wife had arrived up there.
And the father, our son-in-law.
And in that time they were able to,
in that final six hours,
they were able to get a full sense of,
this is happening.
We are not at fault.
If there's anything for us to learn,
we won't be able to learn it through guilt.
We'll be able to learn it through the openness of learning.
And so, there wasn't that sense of,
we've gotta figure this out.
How did it happen?
Why did it happen?
There was just a tremendous amount of faith and trust
in the fact that we'll be shown,
as long as we maintain the unit into which
and from which this child came and left.
And if we maintain this cohesive and compassionate unit,
then not only will we be learning
the lessons of what took place,
but we'll also be, if you will,
most open to the communication from Tiaga
in whatever way he wants to communicate with us
about his journey.
Sure.
Easier said than done, I would imagine.
Yeah, and on occasion, easily done.
And on occasion, horrifically difficult.
And then within a little while,
what, we were last around August of 2019,
and then at the end of the year,
we're into the pandemic
and all kinds of other complications that arrive
when people can't connect with people.
And so, everyone in this world has been going through
a lot of loss and a lot of grief,
whether it's the loss of,
I mean, my teaching partner in Seattle
early in the COVID experience
got a really, really horrendous case of COVID.
Was coming out of it, was starting to regain,
and then collapsed into an internal infection and died.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Yeah, so my main teaching partner
that had been with me here in Los Angeles
a decade ago or 15 years ago,
and he had managed Yoga West
where I was teaching here in LA.
And he moved to Seattle after I started teaching up there,
and I said, "Okay, let's build Seattle."
And we built Seattle
into the second largest Kundalini community in the world,
Los Angeles being the largest.
And yeah, so there's been some losses
that have challenged us.
And this is not a false feel-good attitude.
This is an attitude,
having died myself and knowing the realms on the other side.
I died in a hospital, as you know,
and having known the realms on the other side,
it's not the unknown territory for me.
So, when I'm trying to maintain my awareness
and my connectivity with my grandson
and with my partner, with my business partner, et cetera,
this is a real game, if you can.
This is a real game for me.
This is not a fantasy.
Yeah, not a Pollyanna response.
I mean, that's pretty heavy.
And to come on the heels of your grandchild
is quite the double whammy.
But I think it is,
there are lessons in those experiences
that I think are powerful and instructive
for people that are watching and listening,
because we have all endured a very unusual year.
It's been much more difficult for some than others,
but I think collectively there is a sense of loss,
a sense of grief.
I think we're all trying to process it in real time.
And because it's so unprecedented,
we don't have lifetime experiences or benchmarks
that we can look back upon or rely upon
in order to figure out how to chart the course forward.
And I feel like there's this,
I see this in myself or I feel this in myself,
this urge or compulsion to just get excited
about the world opening back up right now and just say,
wow, that was a crazy year.
Like, that's in the rear view.
Let me compartmentalize that
and let me just move back into doing
what I was doing before.
But there is a powerful residue, I think,
that we're all carrying.
And short of really confronting that in a meaningful way
and working through the complicated emotions
of what we've all experienced in our individual ways,
we're cutting ourselves short from a proper healing
so that we can be whole as we walk back into the world.
What you just described in the pandemic sense
is exactly what we were just addressing
in an individual grieving sense.
For example, you said a moment ago
that sometimes with a deep grieving situation,
families splinter.
And what you just described as a couple of options, right?
Compartmentalize, move forward
is oftentimes what sort of aids in that disintegration,
because when you compartmentalize real events
that are not over with when they're over
'cause there's just such a long tail that follows the event.
They once said that death is like a crocodile
or an alligator,
that the death is in the head.
But for that to leave the room,
there's that long body and long tail.
And in that process of it leaving the room,
if you've compartmentalized it,
there's a lot of unresolved emotions, as you well know.
Same kind of thing that takes place in
the sober world right?
The unprocessed emotions
compound, build up.
And then when you don't process them
in an event upon event upon event kind of way,
it's just happenchance as to whether or not
you can get through it.
And what I find is that
that event upon event upon event kind of way
needs to be in big communication,
like we were with my daughter, son-in-law,
my wife, his parents, and the other children.
And the same thing is true in the pandemic.
Yeah, I mean, there's this,
with this compulsion to just move forward,
we have to reckon with what's going on.
And I can't help but lay that across the tableau of sobriety
because that's my reference point.
But the analogy would be you get sober,
and you think the problem is drugs and alcohol,
and suddenly you're a raw nerve
and you have all these emotions
and they're spilling out all over the place
and you don't know what to do with them.
And the steps are a methodical way
of getting you to confront those difficult things
that you've compartmentalized,
or the mirrors that you don't wanna look into
and helping you deconstruct those so that you can develop
a greater self-understanding,
while in parallel giving you tools
for how to work through them
so that you can become essentially a whole person.
And they're so powerful and also simple in many ways
that I feel like everybody could benefit
from learning about them and practicing them
in their own right.
But the pandemic provides this universal opportunity
because it's been such
a collective global experience for all of us
to reckon in a methodical way
with the various forms of trauma that we've all experienced
so that we can get back into the world,
and on some level perhaps even be better or more equipped,
better equipped to handle significant stressors
as we mature through life.
Thank you for drawing the parallel to sobriety
and the world of addiction,
because weren't we all addicted to what we called normal?
Right.
And all of a sudden, we got sober,
shall we say, from normal?
And here we are with all of the emotions
that were being satisfied by our consumption of normal.
And this compulsion to relapse on normal
as an anesthesia for having to feel these things
that we're feeling right now.
Yeah.
And that is like a relapse, isn't it?
For example, the bubonic plague lasted
for about a decade and a half.
Of course they had less technology, then,
and so moving through it was much more difficult.
But following the bubonic plague was the Renaissance.
I mean, people were so pent up
that going back to the normal, what happened?
Politics changed because the monarchy
was no longer gonna be in charge of these people
that had been suffering at the doorway of death
for a decade and a half.
Music changed, art changed,
science changed, religion changed.
The Gutenberg press came in.
The romantic composers and artists came in.
I mean, the pent-up energy just spewed into
all of this science and technology and art.
Here we are again.
Yeah, the optimist in me really wants to see
our version of that Renaissance transpire.
I think the differentiator here
is that we have this thing called the internet.
And as powerful as it is in terms of connecting all of us,
the pessimist in me sees the extent to which it divides us
and the means by which it pits us against each other.
And instead of,
you would think when we're having
a collective global traumatic experience,
that we would unite and rally around a solution.
It would bring us together.
Instead, I see quite the opposite.
And so, when I think about that
in the context of a modern-day Renaissance,
I wonder how that might pan out,
whether we're even in a position
to have that kind of experience,
given the way our current operating system functions.
That's beautiful.
We'll be back in a sec,
but first, if you dig this podcast,
and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
"Voicing Change",
featuring excerpts from, poignant essays by,
and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight-plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast.
It's a gorgeous, artful compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared therein,
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here at the RRP
and serves as a beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available,
and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet Earth.
So, to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
You know, as you were talking about the internet,
I was thinking about the Gutenberg press.
And for the first time in the history of the human beings,
we had-
Disseminate information, yeah.
We had pamphlets that were the precursors to newspapers.
We had the ability to publish ideas
and get them out to more than just
the people we could talk to.
And so, the human brain obviously
has evolved to handle much more information,
but really, the amount of information
that we're handling today
is exceeding the human brain's capacity.
And that's why the brain gets very sort of self-preserving.
And that's when it turns nasty,
and that's when the internet
can turn into that nasty service
rather than a collective, connective service.
But you think about the early stages of the Gutenberg press,
they tried to regulate it just like they've tried
to regulate the internet
because they didn't like the ability for anybody
to be able to say whatever they wanted to in print.
And there was nastiness at that time, too.
And it sort of resolved itself over time
when people got accustomed to it.
So, what I see happening in today's world
around the fact of the internet
is back to something that we may have discussed earlier
in another podcast.
But the world is a one-room schoolhouse,
and there are, there's a spectrum of human beings.
No one more important, no one more special than any others.
But in a one-room schoolhouse, there's teachers,
there's students that have been in it for a long time,
and there's brand new students.
And when you think about the evolution of humanity,
it's an evolution in which people
either have access to that one-room schoolhouse
or come into it later in their existence.
I mean, I'm trying to stay away from
the thing of reincarnation and multiple lifetimes,
because that may not be everyone's belief system.
But just understanding,
if I don't take it to that direction,
just understanding that everyone
has a different relationship with education
in the one-room schoolhouse Earth,
and that some are highly educated in matters of spirit,
in matters of the mind,
in matters of the emotions,
in matters of physiology.
Take you, for example.
You're like this, and I'll use the phrase,
you're like this Renaissance man
who has this incredible relationship with physiology.
Diet, exercise, competition, the works,
which then also contributes to,
even though it may not be always completely stable,
a far more stable emotional system
than the majority of people that are eating junk food
and overdoing on all of the other kinds of additives
that take place in the food.
That then sets up a way in which
you can operate your business,
which is a business of exploring humanity
through all of your podcasts and all of what you do
in a service to people's emotions and people's mindsets
and ultimately, also people's physiology.
Then you have the people that are
what we might call newcomers.
No less special, no less important,
but way less educated physically,
diet-wise,
emotionally,
and mentally.
And in the world,
back in the ancient mystic and yogic teachings,
it talks about how the majority of the human life
is in that world.
The majority of humanity will be in that world.
And unfortunately,
way back when these teachings first came out,
they created the caste system out of it,
which was the most horrendous thing possible
where people were stuck in these categories.
No, like anything you can do well in school
and you can move up through the grades.
But we have to understand that the majority of human beings
only take their body from the bed,
to the breakfast chair, to the chair in the car,
to the chair or the stool at work or standing at work,
back to the chair in the car,
back to the chair at home,
downing a few, watching somebody else's life on the screen,
and back into the the bed.
And that, as the majority of human habit,
is a formula for the disaster that's taking place
that you just talked about.
And what we have to do
is we have to reach the reachable and teachable.
That's what my mission,
that's what I picture is your mission.
You can speak for yourself,
but I see you reaching so many people
and teaching with all of these incredible people
that you have coming on your show.
Well, that's very kind of you.
I mean, I feel like the things that I've
brought into my life and the practices that I have adopted
are really just survival mechanisms
so that I'm not an insane person
and behave badly in the world,
to put it bluntly.
But I hear you when it comes,
and I don't consider myself a teacher.
I do like to explore ideas with people
who have walked various avenues of life,
and I'm on a learning mission myself
as much as anybody who's watching or listening.
Far be it from me to tell anybody
how they should live their life.
But I would agree with you that the majority of humanity
lives in a very stuck loop that is calcified
or encouraged by a society and a culture
that prefers it that way.
It's consumers on a conveyor belt.
Let's keep them comfortable and make sure
that they have a nice, big flat screen
and delivery food available.
The Roman Coliseum, right?
And you can sort of,
yeah, you can, what's the word
when you keep people sort of fat and content?
Sedated.
Yes, basically sedated.
And that way they become very malleable
in terms of serving the interests of the powerful.
And short of some kind of revolution,
that is a status quo that will perpetuate
and keep the powerful, powerful
and the moneyed interests safe.
And I think COVID, the pandemic, shook that up a little bit.
And some people have taken the opportunity
to look in the mirror and do a little self-evaluation
and a little bit of trajectory adjustment with their lives.
But I think also there's a large swath
of that sedated population that then becomes very prone to,
because some of those comforts are being stripped away
or their status quo is being eroded,
because the more powerful the powerful become,
the division between the haves and the have nots
continues to increase.
We see the eradication of the middle class
and the have nots have even less.
And that makes people,
of course, they're gonna be angry and resentful,
and they're going to be prone to being provoked by
media outlets that understand how to marshal that anger
towards a specific aim.
And that, I think, sows the seeds for the destruction
of the culture that we've enjoyed for so long.
And I don't know how that plays out.
The way I see it playing out is
it's like a spiral where
that entry point of consciousness
leading into a more capable consciousness
that then tries to control the entry point,
what you were talking about.
The industrial age, that sort of evolved time as money
and banking as the exchange, not of goods and services,
but the exchange of wealth at the top.
If we, instead of countering that move of the privileged,
if we just start spreading the love and the understanding
and the simple capacity to comprehend
what is happening in our world,
what is happening in our lives,
and do so in a way,
it's almost like going into an elementary school
and being a good teacher
means that you have to not claim that you're a teacher,
just like you did a moment ago.
You said, "I don't consider myself to be a teacher."
I consider myself like you consider yourself,
to be a participant with some information.
And if I can teach by an example,
and that example has grace and love and compassion
and goodwill in it,
then I will be able to accomplish a lot
with these who are not that highly skilled
or that highly aware,
and will wake them up.
And I believe that that shows that the race is on
between those who are protecting their privileged position
through engendering fear into the masses
and those of us that are engendering compassion
and love and understanding and grace into the masses.
It's a bit of a contest, if you will,
at a spiritual level,
where I think that the race is on,
but I think that the outcome is slightly fixed in our favor
because that's where,
you know, they always say the arc of justice curves,
but the curve takes a long time.
And I believe that the arc of goodness and goodwill
in the human depth, which is the soul body,
however you want to translate that as a human being,
is goodness and willingness to serve.
And if we can outpace that industrial-motivated,
financial-motivated process
while still using industry and capital in healthy ways,
I believe that,
and I've got it in my brain
because I expect to live for a very long time.
I've got it in my brain as to about a 50-year plan from now
that in 50 years,
marking the five and 10-year increments in between,
we will arrive at a place that was like
(mimicking jet roaring) growth curve
that was coming in right out of the depths of the dip.
Well, I would agree.
Yes, the arc of history bends towards justice.
That bend is gradual,
and I think when we're looking at timeframes or timelines,
how long is this gonna take, right?
When I think about this arms race,
I look at the status quo and see an institution
that has a much larger defense budget
and knows how to deploy those resources
to continue to sedate the masses,
manipulate them for their own agendas.
On the other hand,
you have these age-old concepts,
erudite and ephemeral concepts of love
and gratitude and compassion
which the average person struggles to get ahold of,
and are also tools that are much more difficult
to weaponize in the best way possible, right?
Like, we're doing a podcast,
but we don't control the pipes that
channel network television to people's homes every night,
or all the other avenues of distribution
that the status quo controls at the moment.
So, the question then becomes,
how long are we talking about, here?
And do we even have enough time before we destroy ourselves
or we destroy the planet?
Think about the long game, is what you were saying.
And the Renaissance.
Up until the Renaissance,
the only power in government was that
whoever was the descendant of the most brutal warrior
from hundreds of years before was the monarch,
and however much land they had accumulated
was their territory.
And all of a sudden,
human beings began to have an inner sense
that something different is more appropriate.
And it was a little bit like the book
"The Hundredth Monkey" by Ken Keyes,
whereby at a certain point,
enough of humanity,
or in that case, enough of the monkeys,
had learned a particular skill
that it became exponential across the species.
That it was no longer an outward learning,
it was now triggered as an inward learning.
That's, in my sense,
how the goodness, the erudite goodness,
can be, if you will, weaponized.
That it starts to come from the inside once enough people.
I look at,
and my goal, it's 24 million and 240 million,
whether it's 0.3% or 3% of the total global population,
meaning around eight billion in round figures.
This is the audience that we have to achieve
to come up with that leverage
to be able to then cause this to happen
from the inside of everybody.
Everybody kind of shakes their head and goes,
"I think there's,
"I get a sense there's a better way."
And once that starts happening,
that becomes the new pandemic,
the new pandemic of consciousness.
There are studies in bacteria and virus
that show that this takes place,
that once a particular virus figures out
how to outmaneuver an antiviral system,
all of the virus anywhere on Earth
has that same "Aha" moment.
So, they have found this, what I'm saying is not woo-woo,
but it is a living technology within biology.
And so, that's what I'm counting on.
And that counting on it helps me
in the grief of this moment
in which so much of my addiction to normal
has been stripped away.
And I'm grieving the loss not only of people,
but of contact.
Yeah.
Well, there certainly are,
I mean, I like that idea,
and I think it's true that ideas spread and infect people
in the same manner that a virus or a bacteria does.
And there's much to be learned from looking at epidemiology
and turning your attention on how ideas propagate
and cross the globe.
And with these tools of the internet,
that's only accelerated.
There is an arms race afoot,
but there's so much to celebrate.
I mean, if you just look at the
number of meditation apps and mindfulness apps
and the millions and millions of people
that are practicing these techniques now,
something you've been talking about your entire life
that date back millennia
have reached a certain tipping point
where the mainstream has gotten onto these,
and they're seeing benefits.
And that is a trigger point or a catalyst
for greater spiritual growth and exploration and expansion
in so many other areas.
Just get people to sit for 20 minutes,
use whatever app it is, whatever gets you to do it,
and you're suddenly on a very different, gentle,
and gradual journey,
but distinct from whatever it is you were doing before.
We see it in our food choices
with the proliferation of plant-based options now
and the advent of all of these dairy and meat analogs.
And now the cell biology that's creating
these cultured meat products that I think
are going to revolutionize
how we think about our daily meal
and will soon put us in a position
where the idea of slaughtering animals for food
will just seem absolutely as barbaric as it actually is.
Correct.
Think about
the downstream or upstream,
whichever way you wanna look at it,
repercussions of all of this.
Suddenly we're not going to need
to cut down forests for grazing land,
and that's going to improve
the climate circumstance on Earth.
There's so many beneficial byproducts
of this movement that you're describing,
this plant-based movement.
And a lot of people are thinking
about putting plant-based existence to a test
in their own life
that would never have thought of it before,
simply because the pandemic has caused people
to be a little more sedentary,
because there's not all that,
you can't all get out and do what you have to do.
And in that way, eating the heavier foods,
the more fat-filled foods has caused a lot of people,
sugar-filled, to put on a lot of weight.
And so, people are going,
"Wow, how can I change this through my consumption?"
Other people are saying,
"Well, have you heard of this and have you heard of that?"
I mean, you go to the grocery store now and you see,
I mean, just a common grocery store,
and you see all kinds of things that say "Vegan",
that say "Plant-based."
That is a sign of the beginning
of the movement that you and I are praying for
that allows us to make the shift
from the military-industrial complex
to more the agra-human-humanitarian complex
in which we eat food that's food.
We have relationships that are not canoes,
that both people can stand up and they won't capsize.
And all of a sudden, you look a hundred years downstream,
and that's why I feel very strongly about
what I'm working on.
You look a hundred years downstream,
and it looks like, wow,
can you believe what we went through?
As opposed to, wow, this is getting worse and worse.
I do wonder whether it can be accomplished
through incremental change, though,
because while recognizing these movements
and the progress that's been made, the clock is ticking.
And these advances in consciousness
and in technology, et cetera,
seem to be in lockstep with this march
towards ecological destruction
that we as a human race seem intent upon.
And I wonder whether we can achieve
the symbiotic balance with the planet
that we aspire to have,
and that we actually must achieve
if we wanna perpetuate the species
and the species with whom we share the planet
in the current construct
of a capitalistic democratic republic.
Because capitalism by its very nature does operate
with this zero-sum game, competition construct
that by its very nature is somewhat,
can be characterized as predatory
and really isn't simpatico
with a symbiotic relationship with the planet.
And as we see these advances,
they become armaments in the toolbox of capitalism.
They co-op them and use them.
And these are good things on some level,
but ultimately, are we not blind to the bigger picture?
Do we need to have more of a revolution
in order to save the planet and survive?
Your comment, "I wonder,"
is the stimulant.
"I wonder" comes from the root of "I wander".
When we wonder, we wander off the path.
And in that wondering or wandering,
we end up finding things that were not available
or obvious to us in the path
of that industrial, capital, democratic, et cetera,
where it was just going in lockstep into a dismal future
because it was starting to undo itself.
A lot of people wondering
will cause a lot of people wandering outside of normal.
And the pandemic was a really good catalyst
for that as well.
And the revolution that I see coming
is either going to be a climatic crisis
in which everyone has to scramble on equal footing,
or it's going to be that incremental stage
in which we are able to,
and I hate using this,
'cause as you know, I love frogs,
but there's the metaphor cliche of boiling the frog.
If you raise the temperature a tiny bit,
a tiny bit, a tiny bit,
the frog doesn't jump out of the pot.
So, please forgive me frogs of the universe,
because I didn't mean to bring that up.
However, it does make the point.
And the point is that incremental changes may be safe enough
to the powers that are holding on
to the competitive, combative
capital industrial military complex.
And the zero-sum economics is nowhere in the future.
The zero sum of debt and asset is nowhere in the future.
The future is found in "The Hidden Life of Trees",
which is the book about the economic system of the forest.
And that economic system of the forest
is where there's a need, the need will be met,
because the need has a supply that will meet it.
And we have the same thing holding true in the world today.
More food is thrown out because of blemishes
than is needed to feed the starving across the planet.
All someone would have to do is mastermind
the way in which the distribution system
connected everything together.
That kind of economic system,
the kind of spiritual religious system
that doesn't compete with each other,
the kind of political system
that doesn't have one side competing
and combating with the other side,
the kind of economic system
that is shareable and sustainable.
These are the ways of the future.
And to get there, we will either go incrementally,
and if that isn't gonna work,
climate's gonna change the case.
And climate is gonna bring about the revolution.
And the revolution is not going to be, in my estimate,
and don't think that I'm the one that's saying,
"This is how it is, there's no other way."
But in my view of things,
the only way that climate is going to change us
is the way the pandemic changes us, changed us.
And that is that a significant series of disasters
suddenly wakes up the wakeable,
and those who can't be awakened
continue to try to struggle in the way they are,
begin to learn from those who are waking up
and finding a new way in the new environment
to have life in a sustainable manner.
And that's why I say for me, it's a 50-year plan.
It's not a decades plan.
It's not an election cycle plan.
It's not any of these things.
It's a long-range plan.
And if each one of us keeps doing what we're doing
that is positive and beneficial,
I believe that we come out,
and I won't say on top, 'cause that maintains the hierarchy.
I believe that we come out in a common existence.
Always the hopeful optimist.
How far along are we on this 50-year plan, Guru Singh?
I think we're about 12 years in.
I think we're about 12 years in,
meaning we got about 38 more to go.
I mean, and this is obviously round fictitious numbers
that are just guesstimates,
but they're based on a lot of intuitive,
a lot of historical data,
a lot of study of, as you said, epidemiology.
A lot of study of the way other things
at other levels of life have faced crises like this.
Think about COVID and the coronavirus.
It's facing a crisis right now,
and it's got plans to try to circumvent the crisis.
It's fighting for its life.
These are the studies that I believe
can help to show us where we can also find workarounds.
The economic system that you touched on
is really important, too,
and that is that zero sum
where there's the haves and the have-nots.
And in order to have, you have to go into debt to have.
That zero sum base is,
you know, it worked for a period of time,
just like the wooden pole worked
for a period of time in pole vaulting,
and then somebody came up with a fiberglass pole.
Put six more feet on the end result,
which was like 50% advantage.
This is gonna happen in our world, too.
We're gonna innovate something
that is going to find a way through.
Driving out here, by the way,
I was just constantly feeling like,
Guru Singh, you're wending your way through life
trying to find the light in dark circumstances,
and thinking as you equate it to traffic.
There was the lanes and the people.
This, if we maintain our innocence
not to the point of ignorance
and not to the point of
putting our head in the sand kind of innocence.
But if we maintain our openness and our innocence,
the clues, the signals will come to us.
It's called the parasympathetic nervous system in medicine.
If you're into the problem,
you're in your sympathetic nervous system,
you're looking at the problem,
and you're striking the brain trying to come up
with an alternative, alternative.
If you just take a step back
and look at the bigger picture,
that's all I'm saying.
And then address the issue,
not run away from the issue,
that's the revolution.
And what I think that revolution is
is just a slight revolution of the cycle of time
so that we end up entering through a different doorway.
I like that.
And also, my mind keeps looping back
to missed opportunities.
When I think about the pandemic,
I think about all these changes that we could have crafted
from closing off urban streets
and making them permanently
for pedestrians and bikes, right?
Let's get rid of the cars in Manhattan.
Are we ever gonna have this opportunity again?
Look what we can do!
We have a moment.
We have an excuse.
Let's make this happen.
Let's democratize education, specifically higher education.
Now that we're all virtual,
why does Harvard have to restrict
its admission class to 1500 or whatever it is?
Make it 50,000.
Charge less.
Democratize it.
Expand the scope of what this institution has to offer.
There are so many things like that.
Healthcare now being virtual, and telemedicine.
There are things,
we've planted the seeds for some of these changes to occur,
and I think there's comfort in returning
to this idea of patience
and the arc of history bending towards justice.
I just feel like,
why couldn't we have accomplished some of these things
with this very rare moment that we experienced
where there was a window of opportunity
to do something very real, very tangible
that could make such a huge difference
in so many people's lives?
I love your list.
I think this is a phenomenal list,
and I would put it on my own personal to-do list.
Is that 'cause you and I are both always meeting
really incredible people who know other incredible people,
and the web of our network is big, is huge.
And we can begin to exchange those ideas
and not think as in a missed opportunity,
but think of it as an exposed opportunity
that is missed if we don't pick up the ball
and make sure that somebody picks up the momentum.
Urban streets closed down for pedestrians,
all cars being somehow different from gas-guzzlers
by a certain year,
urban gardens, on and on and on,
on and on and on.
Let's you and I make a list of things
that we're going to champion going forward,
because I think that a combination
of your list from your perspective
and my attitude from my,
I think my attitude from my perspective,
if left alone, is disastrous,
because I think that-
Why is that?
Because I think that it's got too much,
it could wander into Pollyanna-ish,
and that's something that I'm dedicated not to do.
So, when I hear somebody like you
talking about what you see as a missed opportunity,
I say: Okay, well,
let's just shift the time so that it's not missed,
but it's gonna have to be done by this year
or else it will be missed.
And if we give ourself enough runway,
like, we got 38 years left in my plan
if we will go with that.
Then we say:
Okay, we gotta have urban streets by the year this.
We gotta have urban streets,
all walking, no driving by this date.
We gotta have this done by this date.
Now we have a chart.
And I think that that chart could be an idea, if you will,
that could be the revolution.
All right, well, stick it in your PowerPoint,
your analog PowerPoint.
I love it.
I wanna keep this to a tight hour,
but I can't wrap this up without
encouraging you to share a couple thoughts
or some seeds of wisdom for people
that have suffered tremendously
over the course of this past year.
Perhaps they were very sick themselves
or they lost somebody or they had their job taken away.
There's a lot of suffering out there right now.
And as the world slowly begins to open back up
and we're emerging out of this cocoon
that we've all been in,
how can you help people chart a healthy course forward
who are in that state of paralysis or emotional trauma
or just very real life struggles?
I'll go back to what I said a moment ago
about the nervous system.
There's two halves to the central nervous system,
and they're not actually halves.
There's more like a,
it's more like a 65/35 split
between the 65% of your nervous system
is the nervous system that keeps you functioning.
And that is the sympathetic nervous system.
That's about 65-plus percent of your nervous system.
And it operates your body,
it operates your emotional body and your mental body
so that it can keep your physical body functioning.
And a lot of that is controlled not by your intellect
and your conscious intelligence,
but by your subconscious.
And then you have the parasympathetic nervous system,
which is the more contemplative,
the more sort of discovery-oriented
part of your nervous system
that's looking for not how to do it
the way I've always done it,
but how can I do it better?
Now, the parasympathetic nervous system
is very active in children,
and that's why children learn.
And that's why education is focused on people
before they're at the age of around 22 years old.
Doing something on a daily basis
to represent and reactivate
your parasympathetic nervous system.
Drinking sufficient amount of water.
Eating food that wasn't produced in cruelty,
because when you eat food that comes through cruelty,
such as slaughter,
there's a lot of hormones and peptides
and proteins and lipids in that food
that are going to affect your own sense
of safety and wellbeing.
And it's going to lock you in.
So, reducing the amount of fat, animal-based food intake.
Another thing is be aware of how you're breathing.
Most people breathe shallow and what's called paradoxically.
And that means that they pull the belly in when they inhale,
and that just inhales into the upper lungs.
But if you start breathing what is a more anatomical way,
you'll push the belly out
and you'll breathe down into
the lower portion of your lungs,
which will start to activate your diaphragm,
which is the largest muscle in your body.
And once that diaphragm is activated,
you begin to have a relationship with two things.
Your subconscious brain and your emotional body,
both of which are centered around the solar plexus,
which is part of that diaphragmatic complex.
That's just the beginning.
So, sit and breathe diaphragmatically,
pushing the belly out on the inhale and in on the exhale,
and do it for three minutes in the morning,
three minutes before lunch, three minutes before dinner,
and three minutes before bed.
Not a lot of time, total of 12 minutes in a day.
Drink sufficient amounts of water.
The first glass of water could be some salt water,
slightly saline water
because that's a more assimilable mixture of chemistry,
because most of the water in your body
is the same as the ocean,
the same saline content.
And I'm not telling you anything that you don't know
because you're an expert on these things, also.
And one last piece.
Give yourself time in the morning
to contemplate your day
and give yourself time in the evening
to contemplate your day.
The morning is a dedication contemplation
and the evening is an analytical contemplation.
And you will start packaging your day
in between what I'm going to do and how I might do it,
what I did and how I might do it better
at the end of the day.
And what's going to happen
is you're going to start programming your sleep
and your waking hours
so that you can work with life as a tool
rather than as a happenchance.
We've started a school that teaches this.
There's many ways in which you can find
information about this.
All of your podcasts explore this.
So, I would encourage people to just do the things
that they have heard and found to be effective
either in your podcast,
through the extension of your podcast, and however.
I appreciate the practicality of those tools, right?
They're very simple, they're basic,
but a lot of bang for the buck, right?
And they're not things that are going to
alter your life dramatically
after one day of practicing them.
There's a cumulative impact of these things.
They become more powerful as levers
the more that you practice them.
What did you call it when you said,
"I don't know if we can change the world in a,
"we may need a revolution."
What was that term?
I don't remember.
Incremental?
Yeah, incrementally.
You said that, and that's what you're saying, isn't it?
I mean, when you're gonna go train
for a ultra or for a triathlon,
you don't train a day and then go do it.
No, you could.
It's not gonna work out so good, but-
You train incrementally
and you look for small, slow progress.
And that's what I mean by my 50-year plan, 38 years left.
Small, slow progress.
And if you keep the discipline
without having to see the results,
that's an important element
in the practicality of an opportunity.
Yeah, I think that's a really good point.
It reminds me of something I've said many times before
that I believe in,
which is this notion that we overestimate or over-index
on things we think we can accomplish in a year,
and we wildly underestimate
what we can accomplish in a decade.
And I think if we can do
exactly what you were talking about,
which is expand the scope of this timeline
and take a step back from our attachment to the results
and just be engaged in the process,
that we will all be amazed before we're halfway through.
That is so cool!
To quote the sober literature.
I Love that, I love that.
Excellent.
Well, I can't let you go without
at least telling us a little bit
about this Kundalini University.
You said you mentioned you have this school.
So, take us out with a little bit of information
about how people can get involved in that,
and then I'm gonna make you break out your guitar
and sing a song.
Kundaliniuniversity.com is the address.
You can get to it through gurusingh.com
or Kundalini University.
What happened at the beginning of the pandemic,
we also had a scandal in the hierarchy,
the leadership of the world
of Kundalini yoga and meditation.
And in response to all of that, I just said,
"You know, the as-is going nowhere.
"We're gonna have to revolutionize things."
And a lady, Brett Larkin,
who is one of the number one on YouTube and Google
hatha yoga teachers had already been doing
the online work for eight years,
and had perfected the way in which it could be presented.
She happened to be a student
in my in-person class in Seattle,
and she came to me and said,
"Let's do this together.
"You're the the expert and the master
"in Kundalini yoga meditation,
"and I'm the expert and the master in doing this online."
And so, we created Kundalini University
and combined it with her version and vision,
which is Uplifted Yoga.
It is phenomenal.
In the comfort of your own home,
at the pace of your own activity,
you can learn so much.
And we're adding new courses all the time.
That's very cool.
That's a very,
what's the phrase I wanna use?
I mean, it's so opportune
that she ends up in your class in Seattle
at just the moment where the world is upside down
and you're ready to pivot your business
for all sorts of external issues as well
into this new world.
And there you have the person who's already mastered it
sitting right there.
And do you know the word luck comes from the word lux,
which means light?
I believe that all of these situations
that happen to us when people say,
"Wow, that was really lucky,"
I believe they're all guided by that light
that is within us all.
That there is a masterful plan,
that if we can learn how to pay attention to it,
we will be guided through the traffic on the 101
or the circumstances in our life and the day to day.
And the more that you emit that light,
the more you become
a magnet for bringing more of that light into yourself
and your life and your experience.
This is such a joy, Rich.
Yeah, thank you for coming.
It's so good to see you again.
Such a joy.
Been too long, but it's such a joy.
So, let's play a song.
Let's do it.
There he goes.
I'm getting my, ah, you did remember to pull that,
that's so intelligent.
Yes, thank you!
Jason, did you tune it also?
Oh, you know,
hard felt picks, everyone.
Try them out,
because broadcasting and being picked up by microphone
rather than going in through all of the sound equipment,
hard felt picks are really an answer to...
(uplifting guitar music)
I'll remember that.
♪ Open up your voice ♪
♪ Rejoice, rejoice ♪
♪ Open up your mind ♪
♪ Let your God-light shine ♪
♪ Open up your heart ♪
♪ Let the music start ♪
♪ Open up your soul ♪
♪ Let the good times roll ♪
♪ Open up your voice ♪
♪ Rejoice, rejoice ♪
♪ Open up your mind ♪
♪ Let your God-light shine ♪
♪ Open up your heart ♪
♪ Let the music start ♪
♪ Open up your soul ♪
♪ Let the good times roll ♪
This reminds me of what we've been talking about.
♪ Open up your light ♪
♪ Let your sight ♪
♪ Broaden up your heart ♪
♪ And let your whole life start ♪
♪ Open up your mind ♪
♪ See what you've been blind to ♪
♪ See what it reminds you to do ♪
♪ And to be as you ♪
Yes, sir.
Love you.
Love you, too.
Peace.
Plans.
Plans, gratitude.
There you go.
I love it.